Володимира Зеленського соціологи називають
одним із фаворитів президентських перегонів в Україні.
І хоча політичної програми в гумориста поки немає,
нещодавно він поділився своїм баченням
ключових для України питань.
- Доведеться говорити, доведеться - хочемо ми чи ні.
Через себе. Хоч із чортом лисим готовий домовитися,
аби лише не помирала жодна людина.
Десь посередині би зійшлися.
Чи вдасться Володимиру Зеленському "зійтися десь посередині" з Росією -
до цього багато запитань. Адже Київ уже намагався
домовлятися з Москвою щодо врегулювання конфлікту на Донбасі.
До переговорів навіть залучили Німеччину і Францію,
аби ті як нейтральні сторони посприяли домовленостям.
У результаті "нормадська четвірка" напрацювала
мінські домовленості, які, можна сказати, і стали
тим компромісом "посередині" з чіткими пунктами.
Утім, вони не виконуються, тож було б цікавіше
почути, як конкретно Зеленський збирається
змусити Росію виконувати домовленості.
Нагадаємо: чинний президент Порошенко обіцяв  українцям
швидке завершення війни на Донбасі. Утім, згодом
йому довелося вибачатися за цю невиконану обіцянку.
- У мене питання по НАТО. Ми знаємо, що таке НАТО.
Увійдуть війська і ми будемо захищені від агресора, так.
Йди домовся тихо. Кому потрібні плакати твої?
Кому треба в Конституції або десь закріпити?
Я не розумію. Ви дипломати чи ви бозна хто?
Володимир Зеленський переконаний: Україні
необов’язково закріплювати наміри про вступ до НАТО в Конституції.
Тим часом Верховна Рада вже ухвалила в першому читанні
законопроект про закріплення в Основному законі
курсу на вступ до ЄС та НАТО.
Після цього в Україні мають провести референдум
про вступ до НАТО, і зробити це "по-тихому" навряд чи вийде.
Лише після цього Київ може зробити офіційну заявку
на вступ до Альянсу, яку згодом мають задовольнити
всі 29 країн-членів НАТО.
Якщо ж говорити про згадані Зеленським плакати,
то Україні свого часу якраз навпаки дорікали
відсутністю належної інформаційної кампанії,
через що чимало українців за "радянською" звичкою сприймали Альянс як загрозу.
- Там можна переглянути умови. По-перше, там
дуже жорсткі відсотки. Чому ти маєш право переглянути умови?
За будь-якими насамперед морально-етичними правилами.
Не ти особливий, що дай мені менше, під більші відсотки, ніж іншим.
А ми особливі у тому, що нам дають під більші відсотки.
Володимир Зеленський запевняє:
умови кредитування Міжнародного валютного фонду для України -
жорсткіші, ніж для інших країн. Однак відсоткова ставка
кредитів МВФ - цілком конкретна цифра,
яка залежить, зокрема, від типу кредитної програми
країни та її тривалості,
а також розміру квоти країни в МВФ.
За даними міністерства фінансів, МВФ дає Україні
гроші під 3% річних. Це дорожче, ніж допомога
від ЄС, але набагато дешевше, ніж на зовнішніх ринках.
Попри заявлену опозиційність,
у своїх висловлюваннях Зеленський
багато в чому повторює тези своїх суперників.
А оглядачі вбачають у цих обіцянках
більше популізму, ніж справжніх намірів і конкретних планів.